[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le premier point fort c'est la diversité
et l'expérience des personnes qui la
composent
au premier tour on à rassembler le plus
largement possible donc on a des
personnes écologistes évidemment moi je
suis issu de du mouvement du mot
mouvement écologiste europe ecologie les
verts donc on a évidemment des d
écologie sur la liste on a des personnes
qui viennent du mouvement de benoît
hamon génération points si on a des
personnes du mouvement de delphine batho
génération écologie et puis on a
également le parti animalistes qui nous
a rejoint donc un des points forts de
notre lycée d'avoir su dès le premier
tour rassembler assez assez largement le
point phare je pense que c'est celui qui
colle mieux à l'actualité
c'est le centre municipal de santé que
l'on réclame depuis des années un centre
municipal de santé
c'est une structure qui est piloté par
la ville qui est financé par là par la
ville avec des médecins qui sont
salariés et dont les salaires sont
remboursés par le paiement des
traitements et des et des soins par la
sécurité par la sécurité sociale et ça
c'est une structure un type de structure
il n'a à peu près 2000 en france qui est
extrêmement attractive et qui est une
réponse à la désertification médicale
qui s'installe sur le sur le sud divine
et qui est aussi une réponse au besoin
d'anticipation
[Applaudissements]
on lance le plan pour mettre en place un
système de santé digne de ce nom sur le
sud yvelines à l'échelle du territoire
parce qu'on parle de rambouillet mais en
réalité c'est toute l'agglomération qui
est concerné donc première première
décision c'est de mettre en place tout
ce qui est nécessaire pour construire ce
centre centre municipal de santé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]